one their first road game Sacramento is
that they've lost five straight since
then by another two point
[Applause]
city especially because a woman's
heartily tips it out Barrett Jack out to
Portland lead
-
potato potahto
serendipity 4kp Hardaway lost it
underneath with a second-year player out
of Oklahoma great score for the Sooners
he's been playing wallet according the
sketchy children 35 cents in the peanuts
fines porzingis another three packs day
22 corners in the opening quarter for
porzingis he's got 11 homes where
Zynga's back to militina fakes the three
looks
gorgeous t-33 minutes ago now look at
the clothes touch very aggressive
let's back to porzingis passed out the
portly wants a great texture away from
Zynga's puts it on the floor drives on
clothes time gets it southwest of
porzingis japonais ting once again
leaders 15 first half points sauteing
and to reign in that life gave me would
not be denied the slicing right there
overwhelming five down a bit low starts
to the first quarter now by eleven on
the open minutes and then completely
turn
[Applause]
fealty the spout still he gone Kenneth
continues to an ollie
z-bo running into the back of them
descendant both Carmelo Anthony and Paul
George now about Casey it's not that
easy
there's eNOS flunked set up an end free
elusive abusive he's in the hooks he was
two for six prior to that poison goes
off the glass banks around 34 to Krista
for zingers and another dominant
performance and this time just posting
and toasting money in the bank back that
he's not staying out of the loop or mark
the line nice feed inside the canopy
beautiful Cantor have really developed a
nice rapport here